[Musik]
hey leute jetzt machen wir ganz spontan
das video
wir haben uns gerade überlegt während
unsere pizza nudeln im ofen sind zeige
ich euch mein derzeitiges lieblings
salatdressing und pizza nudeln ja diesen
wirklich so lecker wie sie sich anhören
das rezept ist jetzt schon online sein
also schnell mal in die infobox schauen
davon linke ich es euch und jetzt zeige
ich euch gesagt meinen derzeitigen
lieblings salat ich hab mir schon ein
bisschen was vorbereitet und so habe ich
hier feldsalat mit radieschen tomaten
und schafskäse
wir können auch gern noch gurken dazu
geben oder paprika einfach das was zählt
und es geht aber vielmehr um das
dressing und das ist ein honig senf
dressing ich zeigt dass immer mal wieder
auf instagram und trotzdem kommt dann
immer die frage wie ich das mache und
was er genau für zutaten reinkommen und
die zeige ich euch jetzt ich habe hier
meine schüssel und gibt dazu allererst
natürlich die zwei wichtigsten zutaten
rein honig und senf und früher das
miteinander
[Musik]
und ich nehme man gerne in mittel
schaffen sind der schmeckt mir
persönlich am besten im dressing als
nächstes kommen die restlichen vier
zutaten rein es sich öl salz und pfeffer
und noch eine fünfte zwischen staat und
noch knoblauch wobei die fünfte optional
kann nämlich auch bei harmlos familie
und habe das dressing gemacht da haben
sich alle 100 hellblau im dressing die
morgens nicht so ich persönlich um eine
familie die lieben das also könnt ihr
auch für euch selbst entscheiden
[Musik]
das dressing ist so schnell gezaubert
und ich mache immer gerne mehr dann
reichte es im kühlschrank hält sich im
kühlschrank bis zu einer woche ihr habt
ihr es sich drehen und öl das
konserviert so ein bisschen und jetzt
habe ich hier noch walnüsse und die
mache ich mit dem hinten so ein bisschen
klein und gibst du dann auf den salat
und dann ist er für mich perfekt
[Musik]
und fertig ist mein derzeitiger
lieblings salat kann ich da rein legen
leute ich könnte jeden tag diesen salat
essen gerne mit einer scheibe brot oder
auch ohne aber heute ist man es als
beilage
und ja ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
und nach machen wir sind verrückt danach
und ihr werde es hoffentlich auch haben
dass familie liebt diesen salat auch
schon sehr
jetzt kann sie auch mal für mich zu
bereiten ist ja auch nicht so schwer so
war einfach hergestellt zubereitet jetzt
wünsche ich euch wie gesagt ganz ganz
viel spaß und nachmachen schaut in die
infobox das schreibe ich euch alle
genauen mengenangaben und dann sehen wir
uns bei unserem nächsten video wieder
[Musik]